one-time rivals now joining forces to
launch a historic
presidential bid this was how joel biden
asked the california senator kamala
harris to help him reach the white house
opinions are divided i think it's great
news i think it's long overdue
for us to have a black woman a minority
woman be vice president
i think it's a little bit risky because
she's a highly controversial candidate
in fact it was biden who welcomed the
tough taffon crime prosecutor
onto the national political scene when
she was sworn into the senate in 2017.
from there she burnished her credentials
as a combative lawmaker the president
has
asserted that torture works do you agree
with that statement and for the last
time
yes or no did you have any
communications with russian officials
striking fear into her opponents
i'm not able to be rushed this fast it
makes me nervous
in 2019 she ran for the democratic
presidential nomination herself
that campaign saw her cross-examine
biden
over his track record on race
generation it was hurtful to hear
you talk about the reputations of
two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race
in this country it's a
mischaracterization my position across
the board i did not praise
racist they buried the hatchet when she
dropped out of the race
and backed him to win the nomination
racial justice is on the ballot in 2020
and joe biden is on the ballot in 2020
and so now is harris with rumors that
the ageing biden may only serve a single
term
it's a landmark pick that may one day
propel
her to become the first female president
and dw's william bluecroft is following
this story for us and joins us now in
the studio good to see you william
so what does kamala harris bring to joe
biden's election campaign
optics balance experience this is what a
vice presidential pick wants
they want that to be um a vice
presidential pick is
always about balancing that ticket joe
biden i even before the black lives
matter
protests and the the the the the racial
justice movement that swept the country
even before that people were rolling
their eyes saying democrats this is who
you have for 2020 an old white man
so kamala harris has the optics of being
a black
woman she also has um
a similar ideological profile to joe
biden joe biden is reported to have said
he didn't want anyone that would
challenge him too much on the issues
they basically he wanted a vice
president
presidential pickup someone who's
basically seeing eye to eye to him
and she brings a lot of experience as uh
as
a attorney general of california as a
district attorney in san francisco
before that
she has she knows how to argue she knows
how to craft a question
as we saw on the report she knows how to
ask pointed questions and joe biden
wants a fierce debater and that's
something that kamal harris brings to
the table
joe biden had a lot of choice when it
came to picking a running mate how are
democrats
uh what did democrats make of his choice
here yeah he did have a lot of choice he
already promised months ago he was going
to pick a woman so really
we were just looking at a field of very
qualified women
um being the vice presidential candidate
now
or the presumptive candidate now
obviously the democratic party backs
that it's not just
up to joe biden who becomes his his
nominee so
the party is clearly behind him on this
but the party is also different than the
voters the democratic voters and many
democratic voters especially ones
further to the left of uh the party
people who might be former uh bernie
sanders supporters are highly critical
of harris's record on criminal justice
on police reform police brutality
when she was a district attorney in san
francisco when she was attorney general
of california
she was not not present but she wasn't
present
and people especially communities of
color wanted to see her take a lot more
forceful action
on those very important issues to them
so she's more centrist than a lot of
democrats
would like what about donald trump and
his republicans
what are they saying what do you think
terry
they're already calling her part of the
radical left
trump's called her phony a weak bad
candidate calling her
mean horrible disrespectful of joe biden
during the primaries
none of this is a surprise no matter who
joe biden picked these would be the
adjectives applied
to her it's really hard to make a case
that she's from the radical left when
she has such a long record
of working with police of working with
prosecutors of working with the criminal
justice
system so much so as i mentioned being
criticized for being two centers for
being too pro-police
um and as far as you know their
relationship during the primaries all's
fair in love
and presidential primaries of course
they went after each other when they
were vying for that candidacy
and they make they make up and now here
we are so
uh donald trump is going to face some
issues with kamil harris and more
specifically mike pence his vice
president his vice president who's going
to be facing her in october for vice
presidential debate
because as said she is an extremely good
debater wherever you might stand on the
issues there's no disputing that she is
a very very skilled debater and
questioner looking forward to those
debates william blue crop thank you so
much
you